JEREMY WALKER: Hello,
everyone.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hi, Jeremy.
How are you doing?
JEREMY WALKER: I'm not
doing too bad.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Good.
Welcome to YouTube
Developer's Live.
We have an exciting show
for you today.
Special guest will be Steve
Rosenbaum and Kimberly
Peterson from Magnify.net.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Hi, there.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We are
actually streaming live from
New York City.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Howdy.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How
are you guys doing?
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Excellent.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Good.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: We like
the forest very much.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Is this
how New York City
typically looks like?
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Absolutely.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Occasionally
we have parrots
and other wild animals.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
So we will also talk
about curation.
So for those of you that have
seen our announcement, Steve
actually wrote a book
about curation
called Curation Nation.
So we are planning to drill
him on curation, which is
something quite new to
all of us, I think.
But he seems to think it's
quite important.
But we also have couple of
announcements later on.
We'll cover a couple of the
events that are coming in the
YouTube Developer land.
So shall we get to it?
JEREMY WALKER: Let's
get started.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So first,
Steve, tell us a little bit
more about yourself, for those
of you that are watching that
haven't actually had
a chance to do a
search on your bio yet.
And then tell us what's
curation, and what
got you into it.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So I've been a
filmmaker and a tech company
founder kind of intermittently
through all of my career.
And the thing that people know
me best for was that in the
early, early days before the web
was actually born, I went
in and sold MTV on this
idea that their
audience would make video.
And in hindsight, people joke.
And they say, well, it was
Monday morning and everyone
was hung over, which is why
they paid attention.
But I sold a show to MTV
called UNfiltered.
And UNfiltered worked
in a very kind
of sneakernet fashion.
You would call an 800 number,
for those of you
who remember those.
We would FedEx you a camera.
You'd record your video.
You'd FedEx the camera back.
We'd edit it, and we'd
put it on MTV.
And this is pre-YouTube.
And the thing that was so clear
to me during the four
years we did that show was that
people really wanted to
make contact.
They wanted to be able
to reach an audience.
They just needed a framework.
They needed a platform.
And they needed some guidance
and some organization.
So that's really kind of the
root of my passion, both for
video and for curation.
And Kimberly and I, for
the last four years--
KIMBERLY PETERSON:
Five years, yeah.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: --five years,
have been building this
technology.
I want to be fair.
Kimberly's been building it,
along with our former CTO.
And I've been out hawking it
and then trying to make it
consumer friendly, with the idea
that the volume of video
that's on the web today, and
that is-- as you guys know
better than anyone--
growing just stunningly, needs
human help to get discovered
and organized.
And so that's kind
of the overview.
And I can dive into some
specifics about curation, but
I want to just--
let me kind of set
the stage there.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, great.
That sounds great.
So it sounds like you were doing
user-generated content
before user-generated content
was all the rage.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: I was
painfully early, yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: No, that's
an amazing story.
So you mentioned that we are
actually drowning in the sea
of content, and human curation
is important.
Can you expand on that?
Why is it that you think
humans are key to
the equation here?
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So if you look
at the data that comes
out of YouTube over the last
four years, the one thing
that's clear is the number of
devices that make video is
growing exponentially.
The number of different uses
for creation of video is
growing dramatically.
YouTube is doing an amazing job
storing and serving them.
But the word that gets kicked
around a lot is quality.
So if you're Madison Avenue,
there are some metrics about
what they consider quality.
But if you're an end
user at home--
and I'll just give
you an example.
If you have a 14, 15-year-old
son, as I do, and he wants to
fix his bicycle, as he did
three weekends ago.
And you're trying to find a
video about how to fix a
derailleur on a particular
bicycle.
Yes, I can search YouTube and
type "how to fix a bicycle"
and get hundreds of responses,
thousands of responses.
But if I can find a site that
has a highly curated
collection of excellent bicycle
repair tips for
teenagers, as opposed to bike
professionals or racing bikes,
all of a sudden, trusting that
curator makes my job of
searching easier.
So humans are the
contextualization, if you
will, of search.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
That makes a lot of sense.
JEREMY WALKER: That's
pretty interesting.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I
think Jeremy is a
weekend bike repairman.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah,
from time to time.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I'm
not very handy.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Do
you make videos?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I
only repair things
in the virtual world.
JEREMY WALKER: I only repair
things if I have to.
So Steve, can you tell us a
little bit more about Curation
Nation, your book?
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Sure.
So when I went out to raise
money for Magnify.net back
before New York had a tech scene
of any substance, I went
up and down Sand Hill
Road talking to VCs.
And I went to all the shops
that you know very
well, big VC firms.
And each one of them said to
me, what is this slide
"curation" you have
in your deck?
Get that out of there.
It sounds elitist.
It sounds like a museum.
And I, for a couple of years,
took their advice and tried to
come up with another word for
the mix of man and machine
collaboration around content.
And then I finally realized
that the word
was the right word.
And I went looking for a way
to kind of validate that.
And found that nobody
had written--
there had been blog posts
here and there.
But nobody had actually sat down
and said, I'm going to
turn this into an actionable
thesis that could actually
look like a book.
And for all of us who write
Twitter feeds or blog posts,
writing a 300-page book requires
you to be both
diligent and a student in a
way that I don't think I
really fully understood.
And so I learned a lot
writing the book.
And here, I brought a copy.
I would sign it for you guys,
but you're far away.
And in the book, basically
what I did was go out and
explore the universe of how
content was being organized,
and give people really very
specific examples of how
curation existed in the
past and how it will
exist in the future.
And it's been a great entry
point for me into this
community of makers, which
I am very proud to
be associated with.
And I think what Kimberly
would tell you is that,
increasingly, it used to be that
Magnify customers would
say, oh, we need a
video platform.
And by the way, yeah, throw in
some of that curation stuff.
And now we're hearing, actually,
we really need a
curation solution.
So the book was a little early,
but not painfully so.
And it continues to be well
read and well reviewed.
So that's pretty much it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Very, very
interesting story.
So did that book help
educate the VCs?
Do you know if they are
reading it right now?
STEVE ROSENBAUM: That's
a fair question.
Oops, I need a password to get
back into this computer, Jeff.
I didn't keep it live.
I've always had good
relationships with VCs.
And I continue to have good
relationships with both our
VCs and kind of the
broader community.
I think the book did
help, actually.
I think a lot of them
have read it.
There is no VC today that isn't
getting pitched some
kind of curation technology.
So video and curation are hand
in hand, kind of hot.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I haven't
finished the book yet.
I started reading it.
And right from the start, you
actually talk about the
business models for curation.
And you referred to a potential
revenue trickle for curators.
And let me just quote
from the book.
You say that "when these micro
careers are knit together,
your curated knowledge can
evolve from a hobby to an
avocation to one of the many
gigs that pay the rent."
So you seem to be kind of
setting the expectations very
low for curators.
And obviously, there are many
ways in which people feel
realized and people are
motivated to perform certain
activities online.
And obviously, revenue
is one of them.
But there are others.
But if you look at the business
models behind
curation, can you share some
more thoughts about how you
think that is going to evolve?
Because ultimately, for VCs
and entrepreneurs, that's
going to be important.
How will the ecosystem evolve in
your mind around curation?
For creation, I think the rules
of the game are fairly
well established.
But I think curation
is still very new.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So one of the
things I've learned, and that
we've learned together, is the
ecosystem around how a market
changes requires a
bunch of players.
So Google, from an advertising
perspective, can say, we want
to sell ads around
curated content.
We think that's a really
valuable opportunity.
But advertisers need
to buy into that.
Madison Avenue, and then
individual advertisers, need
to raise their hand and say,
great, I'd like to participate
in that ecosystem.
And I think there's been some
false starts there.
And early on, I think we
believed that if you made a
collection of high-quality
video that clearly had an
advertising opportunity, that
the money would start to kind
of tick away and come in.
And I think we're now beginning
to see that happen.
And the game changer, which
maybe we didn't know, but the
game changer really is
the flat screen.
It's really YouTube to
the living room.
Because what we know is that
someone will be willing to
search on an individual video.
I mean, when I wanted that video
of my son's bike repair,
I was able to type in
and search for it.
But once I want to see a
collection of videos about
sports, or music, or the arts,
or anything in which a number
of clips have to be strung
together, I really don't want
to have to search from
my living room
couch every two minutes.
I want somebody to have curated
the 10 best Gangnam
style videos.
God forbid.
Did I just say that?
KIMBERLY PETERSON: You did.
Now I'm going to be stuck
on that for days.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Can
we rewind the tape?
I take that back.
I'm so sorry.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Too late.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Someone is now
curating that as we speak.
So Magnify's vision is that in
between the collection of the
world, kind of the content
space, and then individual
publishers and creators, there's
the opportunity to add
value, both aesthetically
and contextually.
And that there will be revenue
that will arrive.
I personally think it's
going to be a larger
revenue stream sooner.
But I made the decision in the
book to not promise that.
Because again, what's the thing
about rear-view mirror--
is things are farther away
than they appear.
I didn't want to make the
mistake of having somebody
come up to me at South by
Southwest and say, dude, I
quit my day job because
of your book.
And now I can't feed
my family.
I think I actually say in
the book, don't quit
your day job yet.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: We've
definitely seen things shift.
A lot of our customers that were
coming to us, say, three
or four years ago--
they wanted to upload all
of their own content.
And definitely, we've seen
things dramatically
shift away from that.
They're really buying into
curation at this point.
And it's because the environment
has changed.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So content
creators themselves are
warming up to the idea--
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Absolutely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --of
their content
being curated by others?
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Well, I think
part of what has changed in
the last two years--
and again, that's how fast
this space is changing.
Two years ago, if you went to
CES, all anyone wanted to talk
about was DRM.
Walled garden, lock my content
down, digital watermark, keep
it out of the hands of all of
the evil aggregators who were
going to somehow steal my
precious intellectual fluids,
or whatever.
Now, increasingly, people call
us and say, hey, how can we be
added to your collection?
Or we want our content to
be part of your search.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: They want to
see their content moving.
And as long as it gets picked
up and moves around the
Internet, that's what
makes them happy.
So it's a really big change.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: And I think
creators needed to get over
seeing curation as the enemy.
And in fact, I gave a talk
at South by two years--
year and a half-- maybe it was
two years ago, in which--
that title was "Creationism vs.
Curationism." And it was a
pretty angry room.
I mean, it was yelling.
And the creators were like,
you're stealing our--
it was very intense.
And a year later, that
had all evaporated.
So I think that as creators
understand that curation
actually helps their-- and I
don't mean to be kind of
pollyannish about this.
It doesn't just make your stuff
get seen by more people.
There is an economic
model evolving--
and YouTube's part of that, and
a lot of people are part
of that-- that I think really
makes it likely that curation
will be a paid profession
soon.
By the time your kids
are out of college.
Depending on how old
your kids are.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So you guys
were kind of switching a
little bit into the
Magnify.net talk.
So we definitely want to talk
a little bit about that and
see a demo.
You kind of gave a little
information
on what it's about.
Can you tell us a little bit
more, and a little bit more
about how it got started?
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Sure.
Kimberly, do you want to
tell the product story?
And I'll prep a little bit.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Sure.
I can talk a little bit
about that, and you
can prep some stuff.
So the company actually started
out as a totally free
product, very similar to
a YouTube concept.
And anyone could come and make
a site, and set up a
yourname.magnify.net
video site.
And either upload your video
and/or bring in content from
other APIs out there, including
the YouTube API.
And then we eventually added a
pro tier onto that where you
can come and swipe a card, and
you can get some extra stuff.
You can get pre-roll
on your own videos.
And then we actually got into
kind of what we call our
enterprise product, where we
have larger companies coming
to us and actually paying us a
monthly fee to provide a lot
of different services for them,
both video upload of
their own video content
and curation.
And that's something that
we started, what,
about three years ago?
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Yeah.
And one of the things that is
kind of fun about this, and
why we like the partnership
with YouTube so much, is
YouTube, in addition to creating
a great opportunity
and awareness of the
preponderance of video--
also working with you guys.
I mean, there are things
you build.
And then there are things that
you give us tools to build.
So as the volume of video gets
greater, some people that are
doing narrow, tiny little niche
sites turn out to need
fairly complex tools to
organize, build playlists,
build players, all this kind
of presentation-layer stuff
after the API.
And so the easiest way is
to kind of show you
a before and after.
And we think it's a
little awesome.
And then Kimberly
can talk about--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Let's go for it.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: All right.
The we can talk about how the
code works under the hood.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: And this is
actually a Magnify site.
This is the TEDxTalks
video site running
on the Magnify servers.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So
let's say you want
to search by language.
Where is language?
KIMBERLY PETERSON: So TEDx has
this whole taxonomy that they
came to with us.
And you can search by topic, and
by city, by language, all
of these different ways that
you can actually slice and
dice their YouTube content.
None of the videos that you're
seeing here are actually
hosted by Magnify.net.
They actually upload and have
all of their various talks all
over the world upload all of
their content to YouTube.
And then we use the YouTube
API to actually bring that
content into the Magnify site,
into their content management
system, and allow them to
categorize it in all of these
different ways so that it's
easier to browse.
And gives kind of a different
context to all of it.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So here's all
of the TEDx talks in Japanese.
And let's just look
at this one.
So what you're seeing is the
YouTube player embedded,
playing on the page inside
the TEDx trade dress.
So for TEDx, this page
is literally
delivered pixel perfect.
So the logo is perfect,
the color is perfect,
the tabs are perfect.
But you're getting a YouTube
experience with a more
granular search and
a more customized
front end, if you will.
And this is fully automated.
So as people from all across
the TEDx community upload,
it's automatically organized.
The taxonomy is baked in.
And in a few minutes,
we'll get to how
the technology works.
We'll take you behind
the scenes and show
you some of the tech.
And it's pretty awesome.
Questions?
Does that make sense?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes.
It sounds like this use case
that you have shown here, it's
kind of video publishing
platform use case, where the
content exists on YouTube.
But you want to organize
it differently.
And then potentially provide
some value add with branding
from the actual customer.
So looking at the this,
the TED jumps out.
There's obviously a YouTube logo
in the embed, but it's
very clear that this
is a TED site.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: And that's
exactly right.
And people at the end of the
video have an option.
What it is is a little
cul-de-sac, if you will, of
YouTube content.
And the curatorial overlay is
a TED curatorial overlay.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: I was going
to say, we provide--
oh, there's no related videos.
We can provide related video
content and things that are
all curated by the TEDx
editors in our content
management system.
So if you wanted to move on
to other videos that they
consider to be related, you
can usually do that.
I don't see one here on this
page, but it provides that
feature as well.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So let's go
to a sandbox site that
Kimberly allows me to break
multiple times a day.
And then we'll show you kind of
how the technology works.
So this is a site called Travel
Online, which is just a
made-up site.
KIMBERLY PETERSON:
It's a demo site.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So Kimberly,
just walk us through what
we're seeing on this page.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: So this is
actually the home page of a
Magnify site.
Everything that you're seeing
here is actually a drag and
drop module.
In the content management
system, you can build
playlists of your content.
And you can drag and drop those
different playlists in
these grid modules onto the
home page of your site.
And they can be really
rapidly updated.
We have a lot of customers who
have a special featured video
of the day, or maybe for
holidays, or something that.
So it's really easy for an
editor to come in and change
out the content really
frequently.
Here we're looking at-- what
are we looking at?
We're looking at a category
of videos.
STEVE ROSENBAUM:
Called Luxury.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: This is part
of browsing the taxonomy.
You can actually bring in these
videos from all of the
different APIs, including
YouTube, that we support.
And kind of tag them up
and categorize them.
And people can just browse them
based on your sidebar
navigation, which was also a
drag and drop module that you
can stick on your pages.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So let's
actually get into the admin,
which I don't know if we've ever
shown publicly before.
KIMBERLY PETERSON:
I don't think so.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: What I've
now done is I've
skipped the login part.
It's like a cooking show.
I logged in it before, so the
cake would be fully baked when
I took it out of the oven.
But this should look to you
like any relatively
straightforward WordPress-style
blog tool.
And let's go to Design.
And we'll just look
at the page.
So what you just saw, the travel
site, is literally
built by a series of modules.
And these modules are all
adjustable, so you can
re-layout the page
any way you want.
You can add new elements, both
graphically and content-wise.
And for a lot of people that
want to build robust video
collections, and then have
them change on a daily or
weekly basis, not having to go
to a developer to make a
change, to say, this
week I want to do
video travel from Ireland.
To be able to do that without
having to change the
underlying code is actually
pretty powerful.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: We actually
also have a type of playlist
called a tag-based playlist that
works really well with a
lot of the discovery
that we do through
our third-party APIs.
So you can actually go ahead and
set up something that we
call Automated Video Discovery,
and run a search.
Basically, save a search
and set it
up to run on a schedule.
And it will go out to, say,
YouTube and bring in videos
that match your search terms.
Send you an email letting you
know that you've got new
videos to come and take
a look at and approve.
And you can tag those
videos up.
And the tag-based playlists
will automatically update.
So you could go ahead and put
some playlist modules onto
your home page with a certain
topic-- a tag-based playlist.
And that content could update
every hour, every 24 hours, or
once a week with new content
just kind of automated.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Are these
submissions typically
moderated by the curator?
KIMBERLY PETERSON: They
definitely are.
Yeah, they are.
We have sort of a whole
editorial process.
It's actually configurable.
And it can also depend on the
search that you're running.
You can set up a search that
doesn't go through an
editorial process.
For instance, if you're bringing
in your own videos
from your own account at
YouTube, you know that you
just want to go ahead and bring
them in and have them go
live automatically.
They can actually skip that
editorial process.
But usually, if you're doing a
search for videos that you
don't know anything about, they
actually do go into an
editorial queue.
And the editor assigned
to that queue will
actually get an email.
And they can come and log
into the admin and
preview those videos.
And reject the ones that don't
fit, and approve and publish
the ones that they want
to have go live.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So here's
a great example.
Without knowing anything about
travel to Ireland, I've just
searched the keyword
Irish Travel.
And I've found that there's
a site on YouTube called
TravelToIreland.
KIMBERLY PETERSON:
There you go.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So I might
spend a few minutes looking at
a couple of their videos.
But my guess is what I found is
a very high-quality Irish
travel video collection.
So let's say that
I've done that.
And I've now decided,
you know what?
This is great.
This is exactly what
I was looking for.
So now we can create an AVD,
automatic video discovery.
And I can say--
we won't do it here, but I could
literally say, user,
colon, and then the name
of the YouTube channel.
And any time TravelToIreland
publishes a new video, my
site's going to discover it,
categorize it, put it in my
Irish Travel category.
And so as you build this
collection of AVDs, what
happens is they get smarter
and more robust.
And we kind of think
this is the--
I don't want to say the
antidote, because that's not
what I mean.
But it's like it's the
ying to the yang of
the growth on YouTube.
Which is the faster YouTube
grows and the more content
that's being poured into it,
if you can build smart,
human-assisted searches around
that and build high-quality
collections, then all of a
sudden, YouTube starts to be
able to surface.
Wow, what an amazing
collection of
Irish travel videos.
How awesome is that?
And humans are core to this.
We think algorithms are great.
We think they get you 90%
of the way there.
But just looking at--
here, let's look at
it a different way.
Let's look at this just
as thumbnails.
If you look at these thumbnails,
without having to
drill in too far, it's pretty
clear that this one's probably
worth looking at.
This one--
these are all beautiful
images.
This one not so much.
I think maybe Clondalkin Travel
I wouldn't look at.
So I'm not looking for talking
heads, but I'm looking for
beautiful travel videos.
Here, let's look at this one.
And what you find is the
combination of thumbnails and
trusted sources starts
to really
make the process easier.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Sounds very good.
Especially given the amount of
content that we are actually
getting on YouTube.
I think we're up to 72 hours
uploaded every minute.
So lots of Irish videos
there, I'm sure.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Well, and
again, the thing that's
interesting and challenging
is as the volume
goes up, keyword searches--
they're part of the solution.
But we would argue that it's a
combination of a keyword, a
trusted source, a curator.
And by the way, my Irish travel
site and yours might be
very different.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Yeah, we
curate very differently.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: But you might
want edgy stuff in the pub, on
the streets.
And I might want beautiful--
and very hard to teach an
algorithm an aesthetic choice
between Kimberly's view
of travel and mine.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Ultimately,
you're providing your own
context for these videos.
And the curation context is what
makes them more valuable.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Since we have
a minute, let's just do one
more thing.
So I've just gone, and I'm
just going to go ahead.
Kimberly knows.
Kimberly is a detail person.
She cares about periods and
commas and all that stuff.
I tend to curate by scooping
up big collections and then
narrowing them down.
So here, I've just added
70 videos to this
collection, to the site.
And now I'm going to go
back up to Content.
And I'm going to build a
playlist very quickly.
And I'll just show
you how it works.
So this site already has
36 playlists on it.
And I'm just going to build
a curated series.
And I'm going to search
for Ireland.
I should spell it right.
There we go.
There should be more
than five.
All right.
So Select All, Add
to Playlist.
And I'll do Irish.
So there's 993 results.
So that's probably too many.
Let's do quotes, "Irish travel."
Well, you know what?
I'll bet they're waiting to
be approved is what it is.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Yeah,
very possibly.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: All right.
So we'll go back to Irish.
So the idea here is
that somebody can,
with a couple of clicks--
KIMBERLY PETERSON: I think
you've already got most of
them over there.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Oh,
good enough.
OK.
So I'll just save this
as Irish Travel.
And then we'll go ahead and
post it on the home page.
And then we'll be done.
So we're going do Design.
So let's say that tomorrow
is Saint Patrick's Day.
And we really want to
put up Irish travel.
Well, we just built
a collection.
This is not my computer, so
it's a little confusing.
There we go.
Save.
And then we'll go back
to the public site.
Change the title.
JEREMY WALKER: While you're
doing that, Kimberly, would
you mind talking a little bit
about the actual integration?
It looks like, from what you
guys have shown so far, you're
doing an integration both
at our Data API to get
information about videos and
things like that, and the
Player API, where you're
actually playing it back.
And then skinning
the look of it.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Yeah.
We're actually not skinning the
player itself, but we are
using some of the JavaScript
API to actually
instrument the player.
I can certainly talk about how
we're using the Data API.
Obviously, we support a whole
bunch of different APIs.
And I was saying a little bit
earlier that there's always
this challenge where we've kind
of built our own language
for searching all
of these APIs.
And everything has to go through
a translation layer.
So our own language can be saved
in our database and have
that search replayed
back at any time.
And then we actually translate
those searches into, say, for
instance, a request out to the
YouTube Data API to do a
search, get search
results, and then
present them to our users.
If a user decides to use that
video on their site, we
actually store your [? UVID ?]
for the videos, the unique
ID for the video.
And then we actually use the
player API to go ahead and
build YouTube embeds
on the site itself.
And the JavaScript
API as well.
To instrument that, we can
actually do omniture tracking
for video, for YouTube
players.
And we also do continuous play
for YouTube, which is a
feature a lot of our
customers want.
So you can get kind of a
leanback experience, where you
can load up a whole playlist
of videos.
And regardless of whether
they're videos that have been
uploaded to the site or YouTube
videos, or there are a
couple of other players that
have JavaScript APIs as well.
When a video ends, we can just
roll through to the next video
in the playlist.
And it allows people to curate
from a lot of different
sources, but provide an
experience that seems pretty
seamless, regardless of where
the video's coming from.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So one of the
things I just did while
Kimberly was explaining--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So everything
on the site is drag and drop,
so what I've done is
I've started to
update the player page.
So you can do a large hero
player at the top of the page.
You can do related
videos down.
And these are all modules.
And these models can literally
be laid out so that the page
is full of content.
It turns out that a lot of our
partners and our customers
really have very different views
of what they want the
video experience to be like.
Some want the video
to be great--
by the way, that's
really strange.
I'm sorry.
This is what you get when you
don't know what videos you're
playing in advance.
But the player page
is very important.
And we should talk about our
embedded player as well, how
we embed the YouTube player.
But let's pause for a second.
Kimberly was talking tech.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: I'm sorry.
I think somebody had
a question there.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
My question was as you were
integrating with the APIs and
actually building your product,
is there anything
that really surprised you?
Things that were
counter-intuitive, you were
not planning on?
Not necessarily--
either about the API integration
or the space
itself or the product?
Any aha moments that you would
be willing to share?
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Sure.
Specifically about YouTube.
Actually, one of the things
that we found really
interesting, and we were talking
about this over lunch,
was the fact that you guys only
surface a maximum of 950
items per search.
Which, when you think about it,
makes a whole lot of good
sense, but wasn't something
that we were necessarily
expecting when we originally
did the integration.
And actually, our integration
was done back in, I think,
2008, or even prior to that.
We had an older integration.
So there was a little
bit of surprise.
But it makes a whole
lot of good sense.
Obviously, pretty much any
search that you do through the
GData API, you're going to be
getting a humongous number of
search results.
And the idea that somebody would
really need to go any
farther into a results set than
that makes good sense.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So how did you
overcome this limitation?
Did you end up changing anything
in your system to
kind of work with it?
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Well,
definitely, we've got custom
code that actually works
with each one of the
APIs that we support.
So we did actually have
to write a little
bit of custom code.
We can't necessarily lean on our
base class for doing all
of the integration with
the YouTube API.
It wasn't particularly onerous,
but it was something
that deviated from kind of a
standard that we had set up
for ourselves.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Jeremy, anything else that you
would like to know about
Magnify.net?
JEREMY WALKER: No, no.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: There was
one question, and I think
Steve alluded to that,
embedding.
So it sounds like right now if
I want to use the product, I
will have a micro site hosted
on Magnify.net.
Or do you have an IFrame embed
of sorts, where I can just
plug in my curated content
directly into my site?
STEVE ROSENBAUM: You just
said our favorite word.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Well,
we actually do.
You would have to have a
Magnify.net micro site as kind
of the base.
It's where your content
management system lives.
But you wouldn't necessarily
have to use that.
If you wanted to integrate the
Magnify content from your
content management system
directly into your own site,
we actually do have an API.
And we do have a bunch of
customers that are using our
own API to actually build
pretty full-featured
implementations that are
embedded in their own site.
We also have our own players.
And actually, this is
interesting, because we had an
IFrame player long before
YouTube ever adopted the idea
of putting a player
inside an IFrame.
And we did it for a
number of reasons.
Not just so that you can
actually switch between an
HTML5 player and a Flash Player,
but because we are
wrapping so many different
players and so
many different services.
So it was actually kind of a
great day when YouTube decided
to implement the IFrame.
Because our customers-- for a
long time, they complained
about the fact that we
had an IFrame embed.
And we could finally point to
somebody and say, hey, well,
YouTube's gone to IFrame, so
this totally validates us.
And actually, people don't
get as upset about it
as they used to.
It's become a little
bit more standard.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Oh, that story.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: So here's
an example of our player.
So this is a playlist of all
YouTube videos that we
literally just spun up
in 30 seconds while
you guys were talking.
You can literally use
our standard skins.
Or you can build any
skin in CSS.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Yeah.
So because it's delivered in an
IFrame, we can give people
the ability to really customize
what we call the
chrome around the player.
So the video player itself,
obviously, could be coming
from anywhere.
And it doesn't necessarily
come from an API.
We can take embed codes.
We can take oEmbed end points,
all kinds of ways that
third-party video could be
discovered and brought into
the content management system.
And then it's kind of
wrapped in this.
It's just basic HTML and CSS
that's pretty easily
customizable.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: And part of
what we think is important is
oftentimes, when we show the
product to people, people are
like, oh my god, I have all
this YouTube content.
And I've been wanting to find
different ways to expose it.
But I thought that I was going
to have to write a new player
or write a new wrapper.
And the fact that this is all
drag and drop in CSS,
generally speaking, makes
folks really happy.
And I just made this 750.
Let's make it 900
wide and 500--
KIMBERLY PETERSON: So there are
a lot of different ways
that you can adjust the
size of the player.
It can be vertically oriented
instead of horizontal.
We also offer something that we
call a single-view player,
which doesn't have a playlist
loaded up into it.
So this is another way that
content can move around sort
of off of a Magnify channel.
We also have some plugin
implementation.
So if you have a Magnify channel
and you're running a
WordPress or a Movable Type blog
or a blog that actually
supports the TinyMCE toolbar
as your WYSIWYG editor for
blog posts, you can actually
plug a Magnify plugin right
into that toolbar.
And you can actually surface
video and add it to your
channel right from the plugin.
And then you can drop players
into a blog post or onto your
site that way really easily.
And we have a number of people
who are using that as well.
JEREMY WALKER: Cool.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
So we have a couple of
topics to cover, so
let's switch gears.
So thank you very much for
the introduction and the
fascinating introduction to
curation and the overview of
your product.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Sure.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Thanks
for having us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: It's just
some really nice work.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Wait, I have
a question for you.
When does the new
API come out?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, that's
a good question.
So for those of you watching,
the question relates to the
version 3 of the API.
And we actually hosted our
product manager, Vladimir, on
the show a little earlier.
We're trying to get a commitment
from him, as well.
But we didn't get a firm
commitment, because these
things tend to have a
life of their own.
We are certainly working with
trusted testers right now.
And I think there is a very
strong desire to launch in Q4,
but we don't have a firm
date in mind just yet.
But stay tuned.
We will definitely have more
about API v3 coming up on this
show as well.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Cool.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
JEREMY WALKER: Actually, I was
going to say, I'll be talking
a little bit--
I think you were going to talk
a little bit about this.
But this weekend, I'll be
talking at the Silicon Valley
Code Camp here in California.
And I'm actually going to talk
a little bit about version 3
for any beginners out there
that don't know much about
YouTube or the benefits of
integrating it into their
apps, and coding a little
bit against it.
I'm going to show some basic
examples of version 3 and how
easy it is to use.
So if you're around Los Altos
and want to see that, that's
this Saturday at the Silicon
Valley Code Camp.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, great.
So it sounds like if you're not
a trusted tester, in the
meantime, you can come to their
event at Silicon Valley
Code Camp, and see you doing
some live coding with v3
version of the API, ask
some questions.
JEREMY WALKER: Yep.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sounds good.
Now, another event that we are
planning-- and this is a
special announcement for you
guys watching, since on this
show, we tend to share
information before it goes out
to our standard channels, for
those of you who are watching
us every week.
We are actually planning to
have a hackathon in Los
Angeles later this month.
We're looking at the last
weekend of October.
So if anybody would like to
learn more about YouTube APIs,
we'll be showing v3 version of
the API, the new Player API.
We're also looking to actually
have some Google
TV folks with us.
So if you are looking into
coding a large-screen
application, you can
do that as well.
We will shortly be
hearing some more
information about it.
But if you're in Southern
California or you're planning
to be around, please book the
last weekend of October and
come join us.
Let's do some coding at the
Google offices in Venice,
California, end of this month.
JEREMY WALKER: Great, yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
So let's see.
I think there is a couple of
questions in the moderator.
JEREMY WALKER: Yes, well, the
first one is related to
hiring, actually.
The question is, is
YouTube and Google
Developer Relations hiring?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes,
we are hiring.
More information is at
developers.google.com/jobs, so
you can see all the positions
that we actually are
recruiting for actively
right now.
And not only for YouTube, but
also for Google Developer
Relations in general, so there's
a lot of product teams
that are hiring.
So if you're interested in
joining, please check out
developers.google.com/jobs.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
And we have one more.
The question is, how many
viewers are in the class?
And I think they're referencing
the class I was
talking about, the Code Camp.
Right now, I think there's going
to be about 30 people
that have already registered,
just for my particular class.
I mean, obviously, there's
tons of classes in this
weekend getaway.
Some up to 60.
So it may increase.
But it won't be an overly
large class.
So if you need a little--
you want to come by and talk
to me afterwards, I'll be
there to help out.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Special one on one assistance
from Jeremy.
JEREMY WALKER: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
So I think we have exhausted
the questions for today.
If anything else comes up,
then please let us know.
Otherwise, we'll see you next
week, same time, Wednesday
10:00 AM Pacific.
Special thanks to our guests,
Steve and Kimberly.
Thank you so much for joining.
KIMBERLY PETERSON: Thanks
for having us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Behind the
camera, we actually have
Jeffrey Posnick from New York
City, for those of you that
were hoping he was going to
be on the show today.
Actually, he was the live
streaming producer
live from New York.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: And by the way,
he didn't cough at all.
No coughing.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Ah, yes.
That's very encouraging.
Jeff, I think we are looking
forward to your full recovery
in time for the cold season.
All right.
Thank you very much.
JEREMY WALKER: Thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Have a good day.
STEVE ROSENBAUM: Bye, guys.